さて、ここのみんなは英語を話すので、私はそれ
について少し恥ずかしがり屋ですが、ええと、
私は実際にテレビ
のコメディ番組のテレビのライターです
、
そしてこれは難しい質問ですが、
あなたが知っている笑いとユーモアについて
いつでも話したいです 私は何かのためにインタビューを受けました私
はこの質問を受け取りますああいいえいいえこれは
正しいスライドのようなもの
ではありませんそれは問題ではない
のであなたは私がちょうど私のパンチラインを言ったのを知っ
ています 必要よく言う
新しい役割を考えてみましょう
。
服をすべて脱いで裸にならなければならないのが好きで、そのようなルール
が課せられた場合は笑うでしょう。
半日以上続くことはできない
ので、私は」  mそれが必要かどうかはよくわかりません
が、あなたの体は
eds laughter
と私は長い間作家として働いて
きたので、笑い
のメカニズムについて話さなければならないと思う
ので、これ
が私のスライドが登場するはずだった
ので、ここに2つの要素があります。
スライドを初めて見たふりをしてください。
共感と意外性
はすでにここで見たことがあると思いますが、
共感とは、
身近な状況や
有名人の印象についてのジョークですが、そうではありません。
ちょっと変わった印象を見つけて、その印象を見るだけで
笑うのです
が、それはとても重要なので、
この有名な日本ケサダの歌手
が誰かに印象を与えて
、その人
が彼に少しだけ似ているとしましょう。
中年の男性が冗談を歌っているようなものなので、面白くないのと同じですが、
その人を
ますますケサダに似せて、ケサダと
まったく同じように
なりましょう。 面白くないのは、
ケサディラを見るのと同じように
近すぎる
ので、
笑いは面白さを保つのに十分不完全にする必要があります。それが
共感の共感です。
次の要因は予期しない
ことです。これは
、通常とは逆に予期しないことを言うときです。
スピーチの流れ
それはあなた
がええと、人々がそれに陥るようにあなたがええと掘るそれらの穴のようなものです
そしてそれは予想外の
ことですそれで私はあなたに私の友人から来る予想外の例をあなたに与えます
hoshemと呼ばれる日本のコメディアン 彼が
高校に通っていたとき、彼はテニスクラブに所属していました。
ある日、テニスクラブはあまり
強いチームではなく
、テニスクラブには双子がいて、
夏休み中に
彼らは練習していて、新しいコーチ
が来ました。 そのテニスクラブ
とそのコーチは人々が練習している方法を見て、
彼は激怒しました
、そして彼はあなたが列を形成しなければならないことを知っていると言っ
たので、すべての学生はlを形成するように頼まれまし
た イネと彼は罰として
みんなの顔を平手打ちし始めたので、
彼は双子に来て
最初の顔を平手打ちし、次に彼は次の顔を平手打ちしました
そしておそらく彼は2つの
同じ顔を続けて平手打ちしたので混乱し
ました
各学生に2つのスラブを与える
と、それはうまくいくことを知っています。それは
悲劇です。学生がチームの後に整列していたのは悲劇です。
それ
は
あなたが期待していたものとは完全に反対で
あり、ホーシャンの物語は悲劇であるということをあなたが知っている予期しないことです
それは非常に暴力的な
悲劇ですが、彼は別の視点を持ってきたので
その物語は
面白く
なりました 恐ろしい経験です
が、彼はすぐにそれを面白い
冗談
から面白い話
に変えました、そして私がまたコメディであることに気づいた何か
は実際に最も否定的な側面に存在しています
o 人間の生活
の例を教えてください。たとえば、
私がここにいること
を知っていて、かっこいい男が私のところ
にやって来て、彼が来て座って
いることを知っていると言います。 普通のこと
何も面白いこと
何も面白いことはありません
が、大胆な人が
彼に名前を付けましょう。
私は少し失礼ですが、
それは少しおかしいことではありません。
なぜなら
、ユーモアが
あなたの人生のネガティブな側面に存在することを
知っているからです。
ある種のハングアップ
は劣等感で
あり
、ハングアップに直面した場合、それから
笑いを生み出すことがある
ので、別の例を挙げましょう。
彼はまた大胆
です。
ハゲ男があなたは私を知っています
たまたま大胆な友達がたくさんいた
ので
、ちなみにバトルが大好き
で、ある日一緒に彼と会っていたのですが、ある
日、一人の女の子が
やって来て、銀行が
短すぎて、 大胆なエセルソンは
、15年間あなたが知っていることを知っていると言いました。私は私の銀行を見た
ことがありません。少なくともあなたが触れることができる前髪がある
ので、あなたは幸せになるはずです。 あなたが劣等感に直面した場合、あなたは
それをユーモアに変えることができます、
そしてあなたがそれを露出した場合
、それはあなたが持つことができる最高の鎧になります
もちろん
劣等感はあなたが望むものではありませんが
あなた
が回ることができれば それを面白いものにすると、それ
はあなたにとってセンセーショナルな経験
になります。
私は人々を笑わせるために働くコメディアンと緊密に協力します。
彼らは非常に
敏感
で脆弱ですが
、彼らは変わる可能性があり、
劣等感を変えます 勇気
と
笑いと
戦いの中
で鎧に関してはもちろん彼らは
彼らの劣等性を示したくないが、
誰かが
そのユーモアはあなたが知っていることを愛しているので
人々の心を勝ち取るための最も平和で即座の方法であると
言いました
笑わないように頑張れば
、その瞬間に起こって、その瞬間に人々の心
をつかみ、その瞬間、
自分のネガティブな面が
面白いものになり、あなたに幸せを与える
ので、コメディアンは
長い間コメディアンとして働いていて、
自分自身も知っていると思いますが、ハゲ男
も私たちが劣っ
ているとは思わないことがたくさんあることを知ってい
ますが、視点を変えることができれば、
それをユーモアに変えることができます
そして
、それをユーモアに変えることができれば
、それ
は最高の鎧になります私はそれが
難しすぎるという
ことです私は私が持っているかもしれないと思う難しすぎる
ことを言いました
勇気があれば、
電話を切ることができ、その中に面白いものを見つけることができ、
その面白いものは最終的には笑いになり
ます。それは
、神の
神があなたに与えたプレゼントです
。
あなたの人生の中であなたは失敗するかもしれませんあなたは
彼が苦労した離婚を経験したジンニソンを知っていますがあなたは
それが笑いをもたらすための単なる計画であること
を知ってい
ます それらのプロットで笑いをもたらすことができる
なら、それをする価値があると
思うので、あなたはあなたの複合体に直面し、
あなたの人生を素晴らしい人生に変えましょう
ありがとうござい
ます